This is the PPOM
-1 OMM Lab No. 15
Diagnosis of the
Pelvis Pre-Lab Lecture.
Our session objectives
basically are that
at the end of the lab,
you should be able to
identify and palpate
clinically relevant
landmarks of the pelvis
and denominates, and
you should be able to
comfortably perform all
the steps related to
diagnosing a pelvis.
you're going to
practice in lab how
to diagnosis and
name these diagnoses.
Please note that
the white slides in
your PowerPoint
are the ones that
are going to be
presented on the pre
-recorded pre-lab
lecture, but all
the slides are
required for studying.
Many of the slides
in the ones that are
not white overlap
with the basics of
diagnosis of the
Anominates and ***** Bone
Lecture, which is also
required before you
view this slide
presentation. So please,
if you haven't looked
at that lecture,
go look at that before
you look at this.
So remember, the
diagnosis of pelvic
dysfunction concentrates
on the ileal
and ***** components
of the Anominate.
You'll need to do a
standing flexion test,
which is going to
tell you which side of
this function is
going to be named for.
The ASIS compression
test is not as
specific as the
standing flexion
test. You can do
an ASIS compression
test, but realize
that it may be,
it's pointing you
towards a dysfunction at
the sacroiliac joint.
So it could be the
sacrum on the inominate,
which would be a
sacral dysfunction,
or it could be the
inominate on the sacrum,
which would be an
inominate dysfunction
or an ileal dysfunction.
You're going to
need to find the
landmarks that were
discussed in the Basics
of Diagnosis
Lecture and compare
them. And those
findings are going to
lead you to making
a pelvic diagnosis.
Remember, when you're
doing the static
exam, you should do
with your dominant
eye over the area
being examined.
Now, we're going
to skip to slide 22
of your PowerPoint,
because the other
material in there is
basically from the
prior lecture, but
for time's sake,
we're not going to
go over that again.
So, when you're
trying to diagnose the
enominate, you want
to check the standing
flexion test. You can
do an ASIS compression
test to see if it
localizes to the
same side, but again,
it's nonspecific.
So if it doesn't
localize to the
same side, there may
be a sacral issue
as well. So the
main thing is you
want to do a standing
flexion test.
You're going to
compare the heights
of the ASISs, the
PSISs, the *****
tubercles, and the
medial malleoli.
You can write down
your findings.
And on the next slide,
there's a little
table where when
you're in the lab, you
can circle different
things and make
it a little easier
for you to remember.
Also, you can try
to visualize the
pelvis based on your
findings, and you'll
have an easier time
arriving at the
correct somatic
dysfunction diagnosis.
There's a supplemental
PowerPoint about
using your hands
to try to help you
visualize what's going
on with the pelvis.
So that would be a
good thing to look
at. That was done by
some of our academic
scholars last year.
And that's posted.
here's the table that
I was talking about.
So, you know, when
you're in lab, if
you find that the
standing flex test
is positive on the
right, you could
circle it. If you
find that the ASAS is
higher on the
right, circle that
one. That would mean that
it's probably
lower on the left.
But remember, if
you're naming your
dysfunction for the
side of the positive
standing flexion
test, you're going to
want to keep it all
on the same side.
So the positive
standing flexion test
is on the right.
You're going to say
the right *** is
higher than the left.
You're not going to
say the left is lower
than the right
because your positive
standing flexion
test is on the right.
If your PSIS is lower
on the left side,
that means that the
PSIS is going to be
higher on the right.
So you're going to
name it for being
higher on the right.
And then you
would check the
***** rami and
say it was equal.
But if it was lower
on the right side
and higher on the
left side, you
would name it for the
lower on the right
side because we
have the positive
standing flexion
test on the right.
Same thing goes
for the malleoli.
You circle whichever
one is higher
or lower based
on your findings.
so something like
that. You're going to
check the ASISs and see
if they're in-flared
or out-flared. That's
going to be based
on the umbilicus. So
if the right ASIS is
closer to the umbilicus
than the left, you
would say that there's
a right in-flare.
If the positive
standing flexion test
was higher on the,
was positive on the
left side, in that
same exact case, if
the right ASAS was
closer to the umbilicus,
that would mean
that the left ASAS
was farther away.
So if the standing
flexion test was
positive on the left,
you would name it
as a left out flare.
And then the *****
symphysis is another
area you would
check, and you could
feel if it's
compressed or a little
distracted or look
for bulging or
shallow cartilage.
And we'll get
into that a little
bit more later.
So you want to follow
the steps that we're
going to talk about
in order. You want
to be meticulous
and consistent with
your hand placement.
Remember the thumbs
go underneath the
ASISs and the PSISs and
the malleoli when
you're, the medial
malleoli, when you're
doing your symmetry
testing comparison.
And the thumbs are
going to go on the
superior aspect of the
***** tubercles when
you're checking for
the heights of the
***** tubercles. So
first you do a
standing flexion
test, then you do
some pine static
examination, and
then you make
your somatic
dysfunction diagnosis.
And there are a number
of different diagnoses
you can make. You have
enominate rotations,
which you're going
to get either a right
or a left anteriorly
rotated enominate
or a posteriorly rotated
enominate. You can
get enominate shears
where you're going to
have superior shears
or inferior shears.
So if everything is
higher on one side, it's
going to be a superior
shear. If it's lower
on one side, it's
going to be an inferior
shear. Then how do
you know if it's which
side to name it for?
You name it for the
side of the positive
standing flexion test.
There are nominate
inflares and outflares,
and we'll talk about
that. You can have
right inflares, left
inflares, bilateral
inflares, or right
or left or bilateral
outflares, depending
on the findings.
and you could have *****
shears it's basically
if you don't find any
any asymmetry with
the nominates as far
as rotations or shears
the ***** synthesis
you you look at the
***** synthesis and look
at the ***** tubercles
and if one *****
tubercle is higher than
the other then it's a
superior ***** shear
and if it's lower
than the other it's an
inferior ***** shear
and again you're naming
the shears if there
are no if there are no
dysfunctions with the
inominates then you
can name the shears if
uh if you if you find
the dysfunction the
inominates you're going
to treat those first
and then check and
see if there's still
asymmetry at the *****
symphysis if there
is then you treat the
shear you could also
have gapped or compressed
***** emphasis, like
I mentioned before.
So what's an
enominate rotation?
Basically, the entire
enominate rotates
either anteriorly or
posteriorly in comparison
to the sacrum.
So if you look at
these diagrams, this
one here is neutral.
This one here has a left
anteriorly
rotated enominate.
So how do we know
it's a left anteriorly
rotated nominate? Well,
you're going to have a
positive standing
flexion test on the left.
You're going to have
an inferior ASIS
on the left compared
to the right.
So the left one is going
to be lower
than the right.
And in this case,
the ***** synthesis
is a little bit
lower, but it could be
equal then when you
flip it over flip
the patient over
and look at the back
you're going to
notice that the
the left psis
is going to be
higher this
diagram's not quite
the best but the
left psis is going
to be higher than
the right so that's
what this arrow is
indicating here.
So if you have a
positive standing
flexion test on the
left, an inferior,
meaning the left ASIS
is lower than the
right, an inferior
ASIS on the left, and a
superior ASIS on the
right, that's going
to be a left anteriorly
rotated enominant.
Now, keeping the
positive standing flexion
test on the same
side. If you have a
positive standing
flexion test on the left,
now you have the
ASAS on the left is
superior than the
right, and you have the
PSIS on the left is
going to be inferior
on the left compared
to the right.
And in this case, the
***** symphysis is a
little bit higher on the
left, but that doesn't
matter. It could be
higher, it could be
equal, it doesn't matter.
You're naming it
for the positions of
the PSIS, the ASIS,
and the standing
flexure test. So in
this case, you've got
a left posteriorly
rotated nominate.
And if you look at
the diagram over
here, for a left
anteriorly rotated
nominate, you could
see that the left
denominator is
rotated anteriorly.
And in this case,
you can see that
the left denominator
is rotated posteriorly.
And in these
positions, you could
actually see better
the symmetry, or
the asymmetry,
between the
PSISs.
Let's see if
I can draw it
before that.
link pops up.
See how the PSS is
lower on the, I'm
sorry, I'm calling it
PSS, this is the ***.
The *** is lower on
the left than the
right, in the right
anteriorly rotated,
in the left anteriorly
rotated nominate.
And for a left
posteriorly rotated
nominate, the left PSS
is going to be lower.
And remember that the
findings as far as
the symmetry when
you're looking at it
would be the same for
a right anteriorly
rotated nominate
as it is for a left
posteriorly rotated
nominate. The only difference
would be the side
of the positive
standing flexion test.
So in this diagram
right here, where it
says posteriorly rotated,
this is demonstrating
a left posteriorly
rotated nominate
because the standing
flexion test was
positive on the left.
But if the standing
flexion test was positive
on the right, this
same image here would
be a right anteriorly
rotated nominate.
So it's all based on that
positive standing
flexion test.
and this is just
demonstrating again
left anterior rotate
nominate has a
left asas inferior
a left psas post
superior tubic tubercles
can be inferior
equal and the
medial malleolus
now we didn't talk
about that yet would
be inferior so if
you have a left
anteriorly rotated
enominate, as this all
comes anterior, that's
going to bring the hip
inferior. So you're
going to get a left
inferior medial malleolus.
And that's if there's
no leg length
discrepancy. If one leg's
shorter than the other,
then the malleoli
might not line up the
way you'd expect them
to line up. And also
sometimes there's other
issues, maybe a psoas
is really tight, so
that's going to cause
malleolus to appear
shorter, and that's
going to change things.
So the malleolus
you have to
kind of think
about a little
bit, but if
everything else is
normal with an
anteriorly rotated
enominate, you're
going to have an
inferior medial
malleolus on the side
of the anteriorly
rotated enominate.
And you would reverse
all of this for
a right anteriorly
rotated enominate.
And what are some of
the complaints? They
may have hamstring
tightness. They may complain
of some kind of
sciatic pain. And that
could be secondary to
piriformis dysfunction.
You're going to find,
you may find iliolumbar
ligament tenderness.
you may find some
when you if you were to
rock the nominate and
actually try to motion
test the nominate for
an anteriorly rotate
nominate there's going
to be a freedom of
anterior rotation and
restriction and posterior
rotation and posterior
rotate nominate is
pretty much opposite
everything i just said
so for a posterior
rotate nominate you're
going to have the asas
is hot for a left
posterior rotate nominate
the asas is going to
be higher on the left
it's going to be the
PSS is going to be
lower on the left the
***** tubercles may
be superior or equal
and now the malleolus
is going to be higher
medial malleolus
on the left because
if if this is rotating
posteriorly that's
going to be bringing
the the leg up at
the at the acetabulum.
So you're going to
get a superior medial
malleolus on the
side of the posteriorly
rotated anominate.
And patients may
complain of inguinal
groin pain, secondary
to ****** femoris
dysfunction.
They may get
medial knee pain,
secondary to
sartorius dysfunction.
And because the
muscles are attached to
the anominate, so as
the anominate gets
pulled posterior,
it's going to start
putting a strain
on those muscles.
You may find inguinal
tenderness. There
may be a freedom to
posterior rotation
testing, where
you grab onto that
nominate and gently
rock it posteriorly.
And there may be a
freedom to posteriorly
rotated motion,
and there'll be a
restriction to anteriorly
rotated motion.
now when you talk
about enominate shears
a shear basically is
the whole enominate
going up on one side
or down on one side
so if you have a
superior enominate shear
all of your landmarks
are going to be
superior the asis is
going to be superior
The PSIS is going
to be superior
The malleoli are
going to be superior
All on the same side
If you have an
inferior shear
Then all of your
landmarks are going to be
Sorry, for the superior
shear The landmarks
are going up For
an inferior shear
All of your landmarks are
going to be
going down down.
So your ASAS
is going down.
Your PSAS is going down.
The ***** synthesis
is going down.
And then don't
forget the medial
malleolus is going
to be going down.
And these usually occur
because of trauma.
You step off a curb and
you go down a little
further than you
expected and you jam your
leg up and that can
cause a superior shear.
If you're running and
you get your foot caught
in a drain or something
like that on the
side of the road, and
you fall forward, you
could pull that whole
entire nominate down.
Any trauma where
you could think of
that's going to cause
a pulling of the
nominate inferiorly
is going to cause an
inferior shear, and
anything that's going
to push that nominate
up is going to be
a superior shear.
Superior shear could
fall, You can fall
on your buttocks on
one side, one
enominate, and that's
going to drive that
enominate superiorly.
That'll give you
a superior shear.
And this chart just
explains it. So
for a left superior
enominate shear,
you're going to
have the positive
standing flexion
test on the left.
*** is going to be
superior on the left.
The PSAS is going to
be superior on the
left. The *****
tubercle is going to be
superior on the
left. And the medial
malleol is going to be
superior on the left.
So everything is
going to be superior.
and what is some
complaints patient may
have well they may
complain of some kind of
pain some kind of
pelvic pain they may
have some si pain too
they're they may just
going to be some pain
you might find some
tissue texture tissue
texture changes on
the same side of the
si joint or the *****
symphysis of the
inominate shear and if
you try to motion
test the whole entire
there's gonna be a little
bit more of a freedom
as you motion
test superiorly.
And the left inferior
nominant shear,
everything is gonna
be inferior. So it's
opposite what we
just talked about.
And the standing
flexion test is still
gonna be on the
left side because
that's the side of
the dysfunction.
If we were talking
about right-sided
dysfunctions, then there'd
be a right positive
standing flexion test.
And these findings here,
if we had a right
positive standing flexion
test, and oh, on
an exam, you get a
question, standing flexion
test positive on the
right, and you notice
the ASAS is lower on
the left, the PSAS
is lower on the left,
and the ***** tubercle
is lower on the left.
what's your diagnosis
well that's going
to be a right
superior shear because
even though all the
findings that they're
naming all the findings
as being lower on
on the left oops it's
hard to circle with
this track pad here
if but if you have a
standing flex test
positive on the right then
everything's named
for the right side so
even though they told
you that the findings
are on the left, you
have to know, oh,
positive standing flex
test on the right, that's
going to be a right
-sided dysfunction,
so I have to reverse
everything in my mind.
So keep that in mind,
because sometimes
item writers like to
be tricky like that.
And again, for
an inferior
nominative chair,
patients may
be complaining
of pelvic pain,
you're going to see
tissue texture change
at the SI joint on
that side, and now the
freedoms of motion
if you were to try to
to bring the whole
enominant into superior
and inferior superiorly
and inferiorly in
an inferior enominant
shear it's going to
move more inferiorly
and it's going to feel
more restricted when
you bring it superiorly
so out flares and
in flares basically
Basically, once
you diagnose,
once you treat
the enominates,
make sure that
they get the
anterior rotated
enominate dysfunctions out
of the way, finish
the superior inferior
shears, then, you know,
treat those, then check
for the flare, out
flares and in flares.
So an out flare basically
means that if we
had a positive standing
flexure test on the
right, on this side
here and the distance
between the ASAS and
the umbilicus on the
right side is greater
I just said plus one
like x plus one it
could be x plus anything
and then this side is
just plain old x on
the left then because
the distance between
the umbilicus and the
ASAS on the right is
greater it's going to
be a right out flare.
If you had the
positive standing
flexure test on the right
and you have a
less distance
between the umbilicus
and the ASIS,
so designated
as x minus one,
so if there's less of
a distance on the left
on the right side here
than there is on the
left, then that's going
to be an in flare.
So you might notice
that the outflare
could be associated with
a posterior rotation
due to the shape of
the SI joint, and
the inflare could be
associated with an
anterior rotation due
to the shape of the
SI joint. So that's
why you want to treat
the nominate
dysfunctions first, and
then go back and
just check and see if
those outflare or
inflare are still there.
And they may
be complaining
subjectively of
a pelvic or SI
joint pain for
these as well.
Now you have *****
shears. So if the ASAS,
PSAS heights are the
same, they're equal,
but the ***** tubercle
is higher on one
side than the other,
then you're going
to have a ***** shear.
So if you have a,
in this case, say
there's a left positive
standing flexion
test, and you have a
left ***** tubercle
is higher, then this
is going to be a
superior ***** shear.
if with this diagram
here on the next
diagram it looks
like the arrow is
pointing up on this
side but we'll say
if there's a positive
standing flex
test on the left
side for this diagram
and the left *****
tubercle is lower
then that's going to be a
left inferior ***** shear
And ***** shears are
associated with *****
pain, and it can be
related to trauma,
childbirth, maybe some
cystitis sometimes,
enuresis, prostatitis,
any issues that are
happening down the
pelvic region can give
you a ***** shear.
But again, you're not
calling it a *****
shear until you make
sure that the ASAS,
PSAS heights are equal.
Because if they're
not, then you have
to treat the anominate
dysfunction before
you can talk about
the ***** dysfunction.
They have *****
compressions
and ***** gapping.
So ***** compression
is an adducted *****
symphysis. And so basically,
the ***** symphysis,
the ***** tubercles
are pushing together,
they're adducting,
they're compressing.
So this could be called
a compressed *****
dysfunction or an
adducted ***** symphysis.
The ASIS compression
test may be falsely
negative or may
lateralize to one
side. So you may
notice that there's no
change in the ASIS
compression test.
Same thing for the
standing flexion test.
You may see that they
may be even, or there
could be a falsely
positive on one side
or the other. So
really with the *****
compression dysfunction,
you're looking for
when you palpate the
***** tubercle, the
***** symphysis,
sometimes you might feel a
little bit of like a
cartilaginous bump.
i'll be honest with
you i have not felt
that but they the
literature discusses that
i you know so if you
feel a little bump
you know pushing
out superiorly or or
anteriorly when you
palpate the *****
symphysis uh could be
that it's compressed
what i like to do is
just just put my hands
on my fingers on
both sides and just
you could gently
laterally traction and
and and medially
compress and just see if
one side feels tighter
than the other.
It's very gentle motions,
but if the fingers
go together easily,
but don't come apart
when you're compressing.
So you would be,
you would put
your fingers here
and then you would try
to distract laterally
and then try to
compress medially.
and as you, if it
feels like there's less
tension, it's easier
to compress medially,
it may be a compressed
***** dysfunction.
So these occur when
the ***** bones are
forced towards each
other at the symphysis,
there may be trauma,
the patient could be
pregnant, could have
come after delivery,
baby being delivered.
Again, standing flexor
test may be positive
on one side or both
sides, and, of course,
both sides would be
a false negative.
There will be no
apparent asymmetry of
the ***** bones, so,
of course, you have
to treat the *****
bones first before you
make a diagnosis of
a ***** compression.
There may be
bilateral tenderness
to palpation at
the ***** symphysis
and on the *****
rhaema as well.
I talked about the
restricted range of
motion when you're
doing the lateral medial
compression with
your fingers, but
there may be just
restricted range of motion
of the pelvic ring.
When you're doing
the *** compression
test, it just doesn't
feel like things
are moving as well.
Talked about the
possibility of feeling
a bulge of
cartilage, and they
may also have urinary
tract symptoms.
So for ***** gapping,
diagnosis is pretty
much opposite everything
I just said for
***** compression.
So basically,
there's a pulling
away from the
***** symphysis
with ***** gapping.
And the worst case
of ***** gapping is
actually a tear at the
cartilage and actually
getting a separation
at the ***** symphysis.
OMT is not going to
help you put that back,
but that's the worst
thing you'll see.
So the ***** gapping
is also called
abduction of the
***** symphysis.
And the SAS compression
test, standing
flexion test,
may be negative
or falsely negative.
or they could
lateralize to one
side or the other.
If it's not a
severe gapping, you
may feel a
little bit of an
indentation at the
***** symphysis.
You can also motion test,
you know, try to
bring the go lateral,
try to bring the
***** tubercles medial
and see. And And
if it gets, if it's
harder to bring a
medial, but there's more
motion bringing them
lateral, then it's
possibly a *****
gapping dysfunction.
Again, you want
to treat any
enominate dysfunctions
before you
call that a gapping
dysfunction.
And this occurs
when the ***** bones
are forced away
from each other.
Similar thing, it's from
trauma, pregnancy,
delivery.
We talked about the
positive standing
flexion test on one
side or both sides, and
both sides again would
be false negative.
You want to treat the
innominates first.
There may be a little
bit of a dip in
between. They say
there may be sulcus
deeper than normal at
the ***** symphysis.
May be tender
at the *****
symphysis and on
the tubercles, and
then often on
the ***** rami.
They may have urinary
tract symptoms as well.
And pelvic x-rays clearly
document the degree
of gapping if it's
a severe gapping if
this if it's if it's
a if it's just motion
testing type of thing
where it's not that
severe x-rays probably
aren't going to show
that these are usually
painful and not easily
treated especially if
it's severe remember
to document your
dysfunctions
correctly these
are just some ways
to correctly
document on the note
So you could read
through those and just
make sure you know the
right way to say it.
So for example,
if you have a right
inferior nominant
shear, you're going to
tell me a patient has
a right inferior
nominant shear. You're
not going to say
there's a nominant, if
I say name the
dysfunction, you're not
going to say nominant
dysfunction on the
left side, I mean, on
the right side, more
inferior than the
left. No, you would
just say right, inferior,
nominate, sheer.
So just know these, the
right way to say these.
So now there's a
case, and there aren't
going to be any answers
posted separately.
now. So a 20-year-old
college equestrian
team member with a
history of depression
presents to your
office complaining of
right lower back pain
and hip pain since
she fell from her
horse during practice
one month ago. She
says her right foot
got caught in the
stirrup when she fell.
She was evaluated in
the emergency department
the day of the
injury. Fortunately,
she did not break any
bones or sustain any
other injuries. The
pain is located in
the right buttock,
*****, and inguinal area,
as well as in her
lumbar spine, and
it's bilaterally. The
pain is 8 out of 10
severity, and it is
worse when she tries to
ride her horse. She
has not been able to
ride for the past
month and has been
feeling very down
lately. She denies any
numbness, tingling, or
weakness in her legs.
So she's on
phylloxetine. She has
a history of
depression, and
nothing else is
significant here.
Physical exam,
the only positive,
really positive findings
are the structural exam
where she has bilateral
paravertebral muscle
spasm, which are
moderate, moderate
paravertebral muscle spasms,
bilateral psoas spasm,
which is their severe
spasms. She has positive
standing flexure
tests on the right, the
right *** higher than
the left, right PSAS
higher than the left,
right ***** tubicle,
higher than the left.
Bilateral hamstring
hypertonicity,
right rather than
left, and that would
be moderate
severity. And the
findings that were
with the pelvic
dysfunction could be
described as severe.
So what is the pelvic
somatic dysfunction?
Well, let me draw
here a little pelvis.
Please excuse my
artistic abilities.
They're not
really that great.
All right. So
we're looking at
this from an
anterior perspective.
All right. So
this side is the
right, and this
is the left.
All right, so we
have a positive
standing flexion
test on the right.
And we have a right
ASIS is higher
than the left, and
we have a right
PSIS is higher
than the left,
and we have a right
***** tubercle
higher on the left.
So if we have a right
ASAS, a right PSAS,
right ***** tubercle,
and I could have
even given you, you
don't need it, but I
could have given
you a right medial
malleolus higher on
the right. I said left,
I meant right. Everything
is on the right.
So you have a right
ASAS higher on the
right. You have a
right PSAS higher.
You have a right
***** tubercle higher.
That's going
to give you a
right superior
enominate shear.
Now, I could have
given you all
these landmarks
higher on the right,
but told you that there
was a left positive
standing flexion test.
If I told you it was
a left positive standing
flexion test, then
you would have to, in
your mind, convert to
a, you have to convert
the right ASAS higher
to a left ASAS lower.
The right PSAS higher
would be converted
to a left PSAS lower.
The right *****
tubicle higher would
have to be converted
to a left *****
tubicle lower. And
then that would give
you a left inferior
denominate shear.
Okay, but for our
purposes here,
the diagnosis is
right superior
denominate shear
because we had a right
standing flexion
test positive.
So what are the
patient's somatic
dysfunctions? Well, if
you were to look at the
case, she has a right
superior nominant
shear, like we just
diagnosed. She has psoas
spasm, which is
somatic dysfunction,
peritonebal muscle
spasm, which is somatic
dysfunction, and the
hamstring hypertonicity.
So those are the
somatic dysfunction.
So if you have to
document on a chart
somewhere what somatic
dysfunctions are,
those would be your
somatic dysfunctions.
so basically we went
over how to evaluate
the pelvis to you know
to take the motion
testing findings and
the static landmark
findings and make
a pelvic diagnosis
remember the landmarks
are named on the side
of the positive standing
flexion test i've
said it so many times
and i'm saying it
again because it's
it's just important for
diagnosing and students
have a hard time
remembering this
for some reason.
So I'm just
saying it again.
Remember, *****
dysfunctions are named only
if the ASAS and PSAS
are even, and that's
for superior and
inferior ***** shears
and also the *****
gapping and compression.
And palatomatic
dysfunctions can cause
musculoskeletal as
well as organ-related
complaints, so they're
useful to check
and treat if a
dysfunction is found.